bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau c'est huit invités voici
les titres
nous recevrons amélie asco chargée de
communication de l'association créactive
nous ferons un point avec elle sur les
rencontres 2016 qui se déroule mardi 22
novembre à montigny le bretonneux et
puis nous entendrons françois de ligne
et l'ex-maire de guyancourt
nous l'avons rencontré lors du conseil
extraordinaire qui s'est donc déroulée
le 15 novembre
il a cédé sa place à marie christine le
tarnec
on débute ce c'est huit invités avec les
rencontres 2016 organisé par créactive
et qui se déroule dans les locaux de
promo paul à montigny le bretonneux
le thème de ces rencontres 2016 c'est
identifier et mobiliser des ressources
pour réussir pour en discuter avec nous
ce soir
nous recevons amelia spo bonsoir alors
parlez moi un petit peu de ces
rencontres
alors je vais vous parler des rencontres
et vous parlez aussi de crack team
inventant pensons avec les rencontres et
ont souhaité ou redécouvrir affecté
d'accord très bien alors on les
rencontre c'est cette année la sixième
édition c'est donc un événement pour
vous annuel nous organisons de 13h à 20h
voire 21h tout simplement un après midi
dédié à l'entrepreneuriat qui s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans une semaine un peu
particulière qui est la global
entrepreneurship week qui aurait mis
partout dans le monde différents
ateliers liées à l'entrepreneuriat
alors maintenant moi c'est organisé par
kick réactif et voilà kreactive est une
association qui existe maintenant depuis
une douzaine d'années qui a été initiée
par le centre d'information des droits
de la femme et de la famille
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et la maison d'entreprise
c'est une association qui au fil des ans
a vu déjà sombre de membres et
d'adhérentes augmenté aujourd'hui nous
sommes une centaine de membres des
créatrices de projets des porteuses de
projets des gens qui ne sont pas encore
sur un statut d'emprunteur entrepreneurs
et puis les chefs d entreprise et ce
type d'événement en fait c'est une de
vos missions qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous promouvez votre promotion plus tôt
alors il faut savoir que nous avons tout
un tas d'événements dans l'année tout
d'abord quand on est membre on a accès à
tout simplement
chaque mois une soirée une soirée avec
une conférence sur une thématique qui
change mais qui est toujours dit
évidemment à la notion d'entrepreneuriat
et puis du quotidien des chefs
d'entreprise nous organisons aussi des
cafés
kreactive pour les membres pour traiter
de thématiques je vais vous donner un
exemple je viens créé ma société je ne
trouve pas que compagnies d'assurance ou
je ne sais pas comment m'y prendre et
puis on fait jouer notre réseau pour
aider tout simplement à concrétiser les
projets de chacun et chacune et chacune
puisque vous l'avez compris on est
aujourd'hui des membres féminines donc
vous aider vraiment vous et d entre vous
à l'intérieur pourquoi aujourd'hui une
femme jeudi 21h58 donc une femme
viendrait à créactive alors créatif
c'est aussi un état d'esprit
l'idée c'est davantage de pouvoir un peu
rompre un isolement
il faut savoir que la création
d'entreprise voilà en fait appel à
nombreuses démarches et puis à tous le
quotidien qui va avec il ya la gestion
déjà la conciliation des temps j'ai
privée vie personnelle et puis toutes
les démarches qui qui sont au fil du
temps des fois parfois très différentes
et en même temps sur deux activités et
de secteurs d'activité distinct on peut
retrouver les mêmes actions où on essaie
justement de créer du lien et puis dans
une dynamique locale implantation on
essaie aussi de
évidemment de mettre en relation et ça a
l'air de fonctionner il ya de plus en
plus d'adhérents exactement on a
augmenté nos adhérents puisque en deux
ans on a quasi doublé le nombre de
membres donc voilà je vous ai parlé
toutes ces femmes
il faut savoir que lors des soirées on
invite aussi bien sûr les hommes avec
grand plaisir
mais vous apporte beaucoup plus vous
apporte beaucoup et demain lors des
rencontres bien c'est exactement la même
chose c'est à dire que on sera ravi
d'avoir la présence de nombreux hommes
voilà alors par rapport à cette journée
on va faire étape par étape
qu'est ce qui va se passer déjà alors
demain à partir de 13 heures on vous
l'avait dit c'est dans les locaux de
promo paul promo poels et voilà ça on
soutient aussi pour pour créactive nous
allons avoir donc à 13h un discours on
va dire d'inauguration d'ouverture
et puis ensuite les personnes peuvent
s'inscrire sur le site pour tout
simplement assister à des ateliers et
des tables rondes ou des focus
cette année on a choisi une thématique
liée aux ressources sur 5 5 axes on va
dire donc les ressources humaines
matérielles et immatérielles financière
et puis personnel aussi donc on va
pouvoir très bien assister à un atelier
sur bien mieux s'alimenter pour être en
bonne forme ou bien tout simplement
utiliser des ressources personnelles et
puis en même temps on va pouvoir aussi
avoir des informations sur bien comment
valoriser l'image de son entreprise ou
sa marque employeur
alors pourquoi ce thème pourquoi vous
avez choisi ce thème
c'était une demande des adhérents 30 ou
kde du monde de l'entreprise c'est est
ce que vous entendez alors chaque année
à la suite des rencontres on essaye
justement sondés et puis d'identifier
les besoins les
les plus évidents à vrai dire on est sur
une thématique les ressources des
ressources on en a tous
après il faut savoir les mobiliser et
puis dans le quotidien des fois on
oublie aussi les fois pendant la banque
voilà c'est d'essayer de faire l'
équilibre entre les ressources qu'on
peut mettre à profit pour développer son
entreprise et puis les ressources des
fois qu'ils peuvent aussi être extérieur
sur lesquelles on va pouvoir s'appuyer
donc ma question va être bizarre moi en
tant que femme si je le rends à cet
évènement qu'est ce que je peux avoir
derrière en fait qu'est-ce que je vais
apprendre
est ce que je vais pouvoir créer mon
réseau bien sûr alors c'est évidemment
la possibilité de créer son réseau déjà
vous avez très bien accueilli parce que
on al'avantage d'avoir une ambiance très
conviviale et chaleureuse
on est vraiment dans un esprit de valeur
des changes
et puis surtout d'entraînement il faut
être très clair donc à partir de là ça
va vous permettre déjà de rencontrer les
professionnels il faut savoir que ceux
qui vont animer les ateliers des tables
rondes sont des gens qui font ce soit
dans le réseau créatif mais aussi qui
viennent de l'extérieur
donc c'est aussi l'occasion pour vous
évidemment d'échanger les cartes de
visite de faire des rencontres
et puis à l'issue de cette journée à
partir de 19h nous organisons un
cocktail networking ou là la carte de
visite est obligatoire le networking
pour les personnes qui connaîtraient pas
alors le networking c'est un moment dans
la journée on va pouvoir aller à la
rencontre des autres présentés très
rapidement et succinctement son activité
pour donner envie et bien sûr envisager
l'arrière pour une rencontre est bien
plus de 17 heures à 45 je regarde un
petit peu le sommaire de 17h45 à 18h45
il vous prenait en fait trouvé en soit
les ressources pour dépasser les
obstacles
c'est important aujourd'hui est
peut-être plus par rapport aux femmes
je sais pas c'est important après femme
je pense que les obstacles peuvent aussi
être différent
il est clair que la vie d'entreprise
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille
donc il faut savoir aussi être capable
de surmonter
voilà assez vite et surtout de savoir
s'entourer tout simplement
et bien je vous remercie puis j'espère
que cet événement va bien se dérouler
mais j'en suis sûr merci à vous et bonne
soirée en politique marie christine le
tarnec
et depuis la semaine dernière la
nouvelle maire de bus en cours elle
succède à françois des lignes et qui
avait annoncé sa démission au mois
d'octobre dernier écouter l'ancien maire
de bécancour au micro de nicolas quere
l'oit
c'est désormais officiel depuis ce mardi
15 novembre françois d'heuliez n'est
plus maire de guyancourt c'est
marie-christine le tarnec son ex
première adjointe qui lui a succédé mais
françois de ligne et reste évidemment
conseiller communautaire et conseiller
municipal françois de ligne et dites
nous quel est désormais comment vous
envisagez votre nouveau rôle est ce que
vous serez un appui pour pour le nouveau
maire de guyancourt de mes premiers mots
c'est pour dire que j'ai effectivement
beaucoup d'émotion c'est un passage de
relais
un passage de relais qui se passe bien
comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez ma
christine mènera le projet de ville avec
une équipe dynamique
je serai jusqu'à 2020 dans cette équipe
et c'est donc avec beaucoup de sérénité
que je peux participer à
ah c'est moi qui sont et ses années qui
sont devant nous c'est important pour
vous de rester malgré tout conseiller
municipal de continuer le travail engagé
depuis 2014 vous avez beaucoup évoqué la
continuité dans votre discours oui bien
sûr parce que je les dis et je l'avais
écrit aux habitants
c'était mon dernier mandat et ce mandat
de passage de relais je souhaitais que
ce soit avec la continuité de l'action
publique
quand on est élu c'est pour l'action
publique notre engagement il doit se
faire dans la continuité
par respect vis-à-vis des habitants et
cette continuité là par exemple les
engagements pris seront tenus
quel a été votre sentiment ce soir
j'imagine on a entendu aussi un peu
d'émotion dans votre voix il y avait un
benoît hamon député des yvelines y avait
une sénatrice aussi présente l'ancien
maire roland nadeau quel sentiment vous
anime maintenant que le conseil
municipal est terminée c'est un moment
partagé et il était effectivement avec
beaucoup d'émotion parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai vu leur défilé à la fois 14 ans
de fonction de maire mais vous savez je
suis élu aussi depuis 27 ans et donc
c'est une aventure humaine collective et
les personnes que vous avez cités
par leur témoignage et par leur présence
sur tout franchement ça m'a fait chaud
au coeur
quand vous disiez ça fait longtemps que
vous êtes élu sur le terrain de vue en
cours quel est votre plus grande fierté
après toutes ces années
qu'est-ce qui vous marque peut-être plus
que plus qu'autre chose alors vous savez
quand j'ai été élu maire en 2002 j'avais
indiqué que la ville trouverait son
équilibre et sa maturité autour de 30
mille habitants nous y sommes
les atouts sont fort je pense au
développement économique au
développement universitaire les équipes
successives ont conforté cette dynamique
là le cadre de vie également mais
peut-être la plus forte richesse que
nous avons à guyancourt et qui fait cet
état d'esprit si particulier ce sont les
habitants l'investissement des habitants
c'est pour ça que je tenais absolument à
les remercier tous qu'on a salué votre
engagement même l'opposition même si
dans certains discours on a parlé de
manque de transparence par rapport à
votre engagement en 2014
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
quelques attaques ce que j'ai dit c'est
clair l'action publique se fera en
continuité des engagements pris seront
tenus
l'équipe a une feuille de route je fais
partie de l'équipe et tous tout ça se
passe en pleine transparence
justement merci françois délégué merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivis
durant ce set 8 invités
bonne soirée à tous
il